y hablemos de los vecinos de afganistán
se vienen grandes problemas para países
como pakistán tayikistán uzbekistán esto
empieza a hacer estremecer las zonas de
asia central como se ve la situación
allí
creo que tenemos que esperar a ver cuál
va a ser el guión político de los
talibanes actualmente ya no nada más
estamos hablando de jóvenes están
deseosos de imponer pues una lectura
rigorista del corán sino que tenemos que
pensar el talibán como diferentes
cuadros políticos entre ellos y este
sector rigorista pero también sectores
moderados y negociadores una de las
principales oportunidades que tienen
talibán actualmente para insertarse al
concierto de las naciones este mil
interlocutores y buenas relaciones
diplomáticas con países como china
pakistán está tan india grande que son
países que a pesar de que tienen
relaciones diplomáticas encontradas
entre ellos lo único que tienen en común
en estos momentos es evitar que
afganistán caiga en un escenario de
guerra civil de balcanización parecido a
lo que está pasando en libia o yemen
doctor garduño rusia ha dado cierto
respaldo al talibán ahora que asumieron
el poder china también ya dijo que está
lista para establecer conversaciones con
ese nuevo gobierno qué papel jugarán
china y rúsia en esta situación
el papel de china es fundamental para el
futuro político de afganistán en julio
de este año el comité político talibán
pagó una visita a china en donde se
comprometieron a mantener los intereses
y la estabilidad de la frontera siempre
y cuando china también respete hasta el
poder fáctico que están llegando también
ahora a afganistán me parece que las
relaciones entre china y afganistán que
han sido históricas ahora son
fundamentales para el futuro del talibán
y esto será muy importante para mantener
estable por ejemplo proyectos como el de
la nueva ruta de la seda con base en lo
que hace rusia roo se acompañará esta
estabilidad porque está sumamente
atenta de que no se desarrollen grupos
políticos en contra de rusia en la zona
y con esto generar zonas de influencia
que puedan ir más o menos haciendo un
balance en el poder aprovechando este
sentimiento antiestadounidense que estos
20 años de ocupación pues han sembrado
en la 6ta -doctor garduño la canciller
alemana lo mencionaba hace unos segundos
ha dicho que hubo un error de cálculo en
cuanto a la evaluación de la situación
allí en afganistán que costó va a tener
esto para la como internacional para
estados unidos y para la coalición de la
otan que estuvo allí dos décadas
pero la reputación de eeuu y de la otan
en estos momentos es muy baja en la zona
y sobre todo después de 20 años de
fracasos de ver cómo las instituciones
que ellos estaban tutelando se fueron
corrompiendo poco a poco el fallo del
ejército nacional y la graduación de una
elite corrupta que incluso hizo que
regalaban a varios bancos nacionales en
este sentido me parece que se tendrán
que esperar diferentes discursos en
donde se tengan que establecer
estrategias a futuro de desarrollo para
el país que van a hacer desde un punto
de vista las únicas formas de poder
resarcir el mal papel ni la imagen que
tiene eeuu la otan en esta